let's do it
ladies and gentlemen welcome back
once again to your favorite podcast
[Music]
what's up everybody welcome back to
riffing with griffin
another solo adventure i'm just taking
this solo road and we going with it
strong today i got some question and
answers
new segment real world advice from a
grown ass man
so i got questions from instagram so i'm
gonna be going through those
i'm gonna finish up my 90 day fiance
because i finally saw the finale
wow craziness and just talk about a few
things that's going on in life
um but i really appreciate y'all being
[Music]
here
[Music]
all right that's it
excuse me stop that well anyways
i had an uneventful week uh you know
since the last episode just so just
regular stuff just regular life
you know it's it's tough i don't know i
don't want to say it's tough it's just
different you know we're trying to live
in this new world and we're kind of
waiting to see like what are we going to
do
what's life going to be like and i think
we're all on a holding pattern of like
how we really want to feel about
everyday life
because this isn't normal like we like
you want to say this isn't normal this
isn't how we
we're living for so long and then we're
kind of waiting like um
you know is it how long is this gonna go
on is there gonna be a vaccine or is
this
thing gonna get better then you know
then you hear news like new zealand
hasn't had a
coronavirus case in a hundred days but
at the same time though their borders
are closed and
people can't travel so but if they're
like okay well we have enough
things there we don't need to worry
about anything and we're not gonna have
any import export or we're not gonna you
know like
how they're gonna live you know so is
that normal now they're like okay this
is how
all the nations are gonna be we're gonna
close everything borders down we're not
gonna let anybody in or out i mean
that's not living either but maybe
they're just waiting for the rest of the
world to catch up but
i don't know are they back to normal
life there's like a few places like
taiwan's another place that they're sort
of back to normal life so
i mean there's hope out there you know
we're like hey are we going to get back
to normal so
you know it's like so when i say had an
uneventful week it was like it just
didn't feel like um
i don't feel like i'm back to myself and
that's
really the the hard part um
you know let's see
i did find out some good news i'm gonna
be in a hbo max cartoon
so that made me feel like yes i'm i'm
doing
[Laughter]
i'm living a normal life
like i um something funny about rachel
but i don't know where it is
you know we just rachel and i are great
you know talk about i don't
think i talk about her enough she's
always like nobody knows that
we're engaged or wear this or that you
know i mean i haven't officially
like got the ring and been like yo will
you marry me now
don't judge me this is because she can't
make up her mind
on what kind of ring she wants literally
every week it changes
and then she goes i found out this is
what i want and i'm just kind of like in
a holding pattern of like
all right so is this the one you want
you know
i don't know i don't know how to do it
and then she doesn't like surprises but
she's
she i know her she wants to pick
the ring you get what i'm saying but
maybe that's my excuse to like you know
keep it
like my fear or whatever you know i
don't know maybe i should just
go and do it and deal with the
consequences of like i don't really like
this one but it's like okay well we can
change it or like i don't know i don't
know how to do it i don't know what the
right thing is
it's a difficult thing and you know
before this all happened
we were already like oh i want this kind
of ring and i was like all right i got
i went and got like a you know a credit
card at one of these like you know
at tiffany's or one of those places like
i'm ready to do it right i'm ready to
spend a ton of money and be like all
right make you happy and then
quarantine hit and i was like oh [ __ ]
i don't know where money's gonna be
coming in from so i don't know if i'm
you know gonna be able to live the same
life for a little while i mean you know
what i mean because
when you're a comic all your money is
based off like it's not
you know i don't got a pension plan it's
like you go do shows you make money that
way you put money away you use money to
pay bills
but like if all the shows stopped i was
like whoa and i wasn't on a tv show at
the time
you know people think because i was on
workaholics for seven years i got all
this money no man that was basic cable
you know what i mean
it was no money and comedy central don't
play pay like
heavy residuals not to the other actors
you know the only people making the
money are the three guys
they you know because they own the show
so whatever deals they make to put the
show out it had nothing to do with the
other people i was just a
i was a hired gun so don't you i know
you guys think you see people on tv well
they must make a lot of money
trust me most people that are on tv
don't make money
the people that make the money or no
credits the one that says produced by
created by those are the people that
make the money
you know so i'm sitting here like all
right and i have savings i've been a
frugal [ __ ] for a long time
so i was but i need to know like if this
i'm gonna make this woman my wife
well i gotta make sure that we're taken
care of for years to come not just like
in the fly at this moment so buying an
expensive ring became like a
you know hey we gotta put this on the
back burner for a second
uh because we didn't know what was
happening we quarantined you know so
but now things are sorting we're
starting to see a light
we're starting to see like how life's
gonna be now i've transferred i've i've
gone into gaming you know i'm on twitch
every day streaming i'm a twitch partner
i'm
i i got deals with you know gaming
companies now
you know so i'm i've refocused so now i
feel more
better and confident about where things
are going so i need to just
boom do it i just don't know how to do
it because now she knows
so even once we decide okay this is the
kind of ring you want i'm gonna go get
it
but then everything we do she gonna be
like are you proposing
i mean so i gotta trick her ass a couple
times i gotta go set up some romantic
thing and she's gonna think that's it
and i'm gonna be like oh no
not do it and then you know and then
maybe during that
do it later i don't even know you know
what i mean like when you're with
somebody that don't like surprises but
at the same time you have to do some
romantic gesture
it's difficult tell me you guys out
there
send me emails or messages on instagram
whatever how did you propose
or you know how do you just do you just
do it like you know
so i don't know so that's been going on
so that you know that's uh that's a fun
thing
i'm excited about it i know you know
like what i've learned from this
quarantine
is cheetah one you know because we're
together all the time
and even when we fight and get on each
other's nerves we work past that because
that's what love's really all about
it's like love ain't about the
lovey-dovey stuff love is about
dealing with the bad [ __ ]
you know that was about understanding
that okay this person does this thing
and
you know it's an acceptable negative you
know my mom used to say this all the
time you have acceptable and
unacceptable negatives
you know like snoring might be an
acceptable negative
you know you know her taking too long to
get ready when we go someplace
una acceptable negative you have to
decide what your unacceptable
and acceptable negatives are and when
you
um when you figure that out then you see
how it meshes with the person but this
quarantine is really like
fast-tracked you know hey can we live
together hey can we
get along and it's it's great you know
so for all you the relationships out
there that are working because you know
that you found out it was tested during
the quarantine good for you
and also good for the people that
realize oh i got to get away from this
[ __ ] you you guys too good for
you guys right there too
all right let's get to um
i know last week on the episode i was
talking a lot about this show
90 day fiance the other way so now they
had i
i finished the season i know everything
that happened and then
they had the the the tell-all which i
love all these dumb reality shows
my favorite part of the dumb reality
show is the tell-all
final like final two episodes where they
all come back
they've all watched the show and now
they can come back and be like whoa
what the [ __ ] did i just see or they can
um
realize how terrible their behavior is
you know and so i found out
you know uh what's her face laura
and aladdin right wait let me get make
sure i get
let me make sure i get all these
people's names right
all right 90 day the other way uh the
the final uh you know two episodes but i
saw
everything okay so jenny and submit
turns out this [ __ ] is married
and he's a coward that's really what it
is
so he was in an arranged marriage in
india
and you know he says he doesn't love his
wife but who knows i don't believe the
dude
somebody sent me a message told me that
the dude was lying about what he looked
like when he first met her okay
listen the fact that they if they love
each other or not
it does seem like they have genuine
feelings for each other right
but i also feel like the dude is caught
up in the show i think he
used jenny as a way of
telling his parents and rebelling
against the culture of
arranged marriages and his family and
letting his wife know in the most
worst possible way i don't love you
dad i don't agree with how we live and
i'm showing you how i'm showing the
world i'm doing the most possible thing
i'm finding some american woman and even
worse some
you know well not even worse i'm just
saying it don't look like a relationship
that should work
it's basically he just went out of his
way to make it like crazy and i think in
the process they actually have real
genuine feelings for each other but damn
you're gonna he lied to this woman for
years apparently they've been like
talking on the internet or going back
and forth for like six seven years
and then in that process he got married
to another woman who knows what he was
doing with this lady so i don't trust
this [ __ ] submit
and i think it's terrible and i think
it's terrible for poor jenny
because you get it she's 60 she's lived
her life she got
grandkids and now she's sitting here
like well i want to do stuff for my life
again
you know i raised girls you know she
obviously had a tough
she obviously had a tough time dealing
with the fact that her daughter was a
lesbian
you could see that they had like a thing
at first and then she got over that
and so she went through a lot of stuff
you know as a parent
and getting into her older age dealing
with that stuff and she's found herself
like okay i've dealt with that i love my
daughter and her wife and now i want my
own thing
and she just chose wrong you know she
made it difficult for herself
you know she went on the internet and
found some [ __ ] in india you
know what i mean like what
and then so that [ __ ] is crazy so they
did their thing
uh jahoon and devin uh he that dude is
funny
you just like him and he's just
he just is a boy you know he's just a
boy he just keeps lying because he
doesn't know how to face this woman and
be like
yo i'm irresponsible you know what i
mean
he irresponsible he don't save money
turns out the motherfucker's a criminal
he was selling stolen phones in china
you know so he got thousand dollars in
debt and who knows if that's even true
it's probably even more
to get off its criminal record so this
dude is a
he crazy but he's funny you like him you
want him to succeed
and devin's sweet you know she's just
young you know she young she said she
hadn't had sex in a year
and then she got with this asian dude
from you know some some foreign dude
from uh
you know korea comes over and then she
just lets him bust all in her
and then she gets pregnant and she
already got a monster daughter as it is
so it's like i i don't get it and then
she's you know living with her family
she got a good job but that money's not
going to pay bills it's going to like
you know
she's taking care of her kid but she
don't make enough to run a household by
herself either that's why she lived with
her family you know what i mean which i
understand
you know so but you still feel
comfortable if your family's there for
and you care they care for you and they
want you to you know be okay i totally
get that
so the money that she makes can go
towards taking care of her daughter and
living her life okay
so then she gave all that up to go be
with some dude that she thought had an
apartment and this [ __ ] living
with his parents
and got debt and the criminal record so
that's just crazy
and then um what's the face paul and
karina's karina didn't even show up she
wasn't even on a video chat
she probably you know who knows what the
situation was that i don't have much to
say about this this
paul and this dude paul i mean i have
the same the problem i have with paul
actually let's go over this the problem
i have with uh
submit paul j
hoon all right these guys
they mama's boys you know like paul's
mom came
and like they always show paul's mom and
she always talking about
hey you know you need to be a man and
step
up hey [ __ ] then why you have
him living at your house till he's 30
something years old
on the internet freaking you know
talking to foreign chicks and giving
them all his money
and now you want to tell him he need to
be a man well treat him like a man kick
his ass out
so he can go get a real job and take
care of himself
it's it's amazing to me how they go you
know they
baby people like these moms these
parents they
baby their kids they got them living in
the house in their 30s and then they
want to also get on them for being like
you need to be an adult treat them like
an adult
you treating them like a [ __ ] child
if you treat your kids like a child in
their 30s they're going to act like a
child
they're going to act like a child and
that's what these boys they're just
boys this dude who live in a one
like he live in a little ass apartment
with his parents
and he you know he don't even know how
to be responsible and you wondering why
he got a chick from the america pregnant
it's like what
and then mom's mean his mom is mean
straight up was like oh she's not cute
and you know
the language barrier is weird because
because jehu just speaks the truth
because
that's how you can't it's hard to
translate
you know trying to sugar coat it's hard
to sugarcoat [ __ ] when you translate
so he's like she had the the host asked
him did your mom wish that
devon was korean and he's like yeah
you know and then they showed her mom
some unh some hidden footage where the
mom's like
yeah she's not cute and i wish that you
know
and it's like damn that's [ __ ] up
because at this point now it's like
that's your grandkid and they living
with you uh she's there it's like you
may
that but i understand old school parents
they come from a different world
you know tribal it's like i want my son
to be with a woman that looks like me
whatever whatever their thing is but
anyways getting back to this
if you're a parent don't complain about
your kid
who's living at home because you let
them live at home
it's simple you kick this [ __ ]
out you know
yes you can make sure they okay maybe
you're gonna help a little bit
but you can't complain that your kid is
acting like a kid
in their adult when you got them living
at home
okay i can't stand that and that's
basically the thing right there
so paul j hoon uh summit and in some
ways corey too that guy on the show too
corey he's another one you know he was
living at home too living on his little
[ __ ] farm
you know and oh his father god rest his
soul his father was the salt of the
earth and during the show his father
died so that was really sad
and he was dealing with that and that's
the one time that [ __ ] evelyn
actually acted like okay i'm uh
let me act like a nice person and she
did for that one time
so i don't know so
all right so that's jehoon and devin
okay which is crazy
all right and then uh okay we did we
talked about paul
whatever with him now let's get to the
nitty the juicy stuff okay
evelyn and corey again evelyn and corey
turns out she's a monster man i'm sorry
she's telling him they're not gonna get
married because he's too fat now
he's fat he needs to work out she got
all these excuses right
and he's sitting there just taking it
like i don't get it
he's like i love her you know
what what and then to top it all
off she don't got the ring on and it's
blazing up just
just brazing about it just like i don't
she got her hands up like
i'm not wearing your ring it's like wow
how evil is that and then the best
friend come on
or or his only friend there who's a
friend of evelyn
turns out like the dude told him like yo
i got feelings for your girl we actually
hooked up right
now they show the dude telling his he
coming on talking about
yeah i got feelings for her you know i
want to be with her
and if they don't if it doesn't work out
with them i want to be with them
and now that cory's all mad about it but
hey you know what
i'm with dude whatever his name was i'm
with him
listen if you got feelings for somebody
own that [ __ ] you know it's better that
he tell him straight up
yo i'm a rival i'm your friend and this
is why i'm telling you
i got feelings for her we hooked up
maybe it's best that i
remove myself in the picture because
that'd be the thing to do but first you
got to be honest you can't just be he
shouldn't be sitting there lying
pretending like he's happy for them if
he's not
then you know where you stand at least
corey could be like okay i gotta watch
this dude now
because that's basically what your
friend is saying if you're a real friend
you got to be like damn
i have inappropriate feelings for
your girl just your friend you go ugh
because we had a
previous relationship maybe it's best i
removed myself from this situation
or you're also telling your friend like
yo man keep your guard up you're not
saying that but that's basically what
you
you're doing when you go yo i kind of
like your girl
and we have this thing but i listen i am
happy for you
i think both those things can be true i
think you can
care for your friend and also have
feelings for his girl
you know what i mean i think that's a
real [ __ ] and so then you have to know
that
you're addressing it once you put it out
in the open then you can now
deal with it because then it becomes
then it's on you
when you do that you put it on you
because now you're saying like okay
well if you're a good person you're
gonna be like all right i gotta stop
doing this or remove myself
or or you're say even saying hey this is
a warning like look out i'm coming for
your girl
and then your friend could be like okay
whoa now we know we're not really
friends anymore or i could be like i
gotta watch this [ __ ] either way
i think it was important for the dude to
say yo i got feelings for your girl
and then she she just loves it she's
like oh everybody's fighting for me you
know
but again when she held her hands i was
like i don't got the ring on i was like
what are you doing dude
what are you doing
my god all right then there's the other
one
laura and aladdin all right this poor
chick man
you know she's realizing that this dude
was just using her for money you know
which is like
and it's a shame because when you see
her and you see him
unfortunately that's our first thought
you know in the same way when you see an
older guy and like a
weight younger girl i get that you
people send me messages like
oh man you know she gonna break your
heart she's just using you whatever the
people think
that's your natural indication because
that's an insult to me
and it's an insult to laura because
you're saying you're looking at laura
and going
what are you this dude got a six-pack
he's young he's handsome he's like you
know like
why would he be with her that's the
feeling that you get when you see a
couple like that
unfortunately that turned out to be the
actual case
you know he was just using her
apparently from for for paying
rent or whatever i i just don't get it i
don't get and
and i also think that the show plays a
factor
i think like with that with summit and
jenny
it plays a factor okay the show itself
because they do get money
for the show there is notoriety there is
something about oh we're on this show
so i think that alan didn't love that i
think he played that up and was like oh
because he brought laura over to the
[ __ ] qatar they went to tunisia
he got his family dancing and singing
and he's getting money from the family
i think the whole thing is a scam for
him so he had this wedding party where
his friends gave him money for the
wedding that's part of the thing
he was like okay i got that money i got
her money for paying rent
and i got money from the show and look
at me i'm on tv
so that dude's a [ __ ] and he's
gonna get his
straight up he gonna get his all right
and she just like
you know and then her just like jenny
she's all like i love him you know and
it's like what
like what are you talking about oh my
god
and then her son is an [ __ ] her son
another one who is getting taken care of
like
the son told aladdin like well
you you can't have a baby because she's
not gonna she's gonna forget about me
it was all me me me me me and then he's
a sore winner
like he he he had been against this
relationship from the beginning
he's talking [ __ ] the whole time you
know and then he's on the show
with smiling making his mom feel like
[ __ ] man
i i thought that was terrible like the
mom's crying
she obviously feels bad about this
terrible situation she's in
and her son act like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
man
it's like that's not necessary you know
it's like
yeah she uh he he's the worst you know
what i mean
i thought he was a nice kid before but
after seeing that i was like that's rude
you're gonna
you're gonna clown your mom on national
television this is [ __ ] man
but she she made a bad choice you know
it is what it is
i left this one for last because this
one pisses me off the most
ronald and tiffany okay
to recap they in some romance he lives
in south africa
he reveals later he has a gambling
addiction and a criminal record because
of his gambling addiction all right she
says
i'm still okay you hurt me and whatever
the trust is broken but i'm still gonna
come to south africa
with this eight-year-old that the the
dude ronald has bonded with
and daniel the little kid daniel's
sweetest kid he is so sweet
such a such a she's doing a great job
raising him because you can tell because
he's just a loving
great kid you know good it seemed like
he gonna have a good head on his
shoulders and he's calling the dude dad
you're gonna take everybody to south
africa to marry him
now he has a bachelor party and this is
some [ __ ] that i just i can't stand this
you know you have a bachelor party
they're strippers
and the you know this girl is like i
don't want strippers i don't want you
drinking
the friends of course they took him
drinking and they had a stripper
right it's like some women just don't
like that
i'm watching this with rachel and she's
made it clear if that's what you're
going to be doing
we are not going to get married so
listen you have to know what kind of
woman you're with
you really do is some kind of rite of
passage to have a stripper system no
it's not
it's just a choice i ain't gonna do that
i'm actually gonna suggest why don't we
just have a joint party and you know so
you can
because i don't care i i you know if if
if an
act like that is gonna make your woman
so angry because some women just don't
care
that you know there's a lot of women who
are like make sure you have strippers
have fun that's your last night you know
and they know because they feel secure
in their relationship
people that feel secure and also
themselves you know these women that
feel securing themselves in their
relationship who are just like okay go
do your thing
you know they just don't have their
jealousy isn't about
that oh you know the lucky ones out
there right
[Laughter]
and then there's the times when your
girl just she can't deal with it
you just have to accept that and it's up
to you to be like like i don't
i'm at an age right now where i don't
give a [ __ ] about that i never like
strippers anyway i don't like strip
clubs and that kind of stuff anyway
there's something wrong with it then i
become eric savajo
you know i want to talk to him like why
are you doing this who hurt you what
happened
you know i just that's just my it
doesn't do anything for me
you know so anyways so she's making a
whole big deal about that
here's my problem with tiffany okay
first of all
if you're gonna move your whole [ __ ]
over to south africa
you you she keeps saying like she said
on the show i'll never fully trust him
i saw the dude started crying that hurt
him what the [ __ ] are you talking about
you're never gonna fully trust him then
what the [ __ ] are you doing
there what are you doing with him at
some point
he has to be able to build and earn the
trust back
if you just outright saying like i i
can't trust him then what the [ __ ] he
supposed to do
you're saying you love him he's saying
he loves you the dude went to rehab he's
got a problem he's trying to work on it
you know
at certain point you have to let him
know all right you can earn the trust
back but she's like
you know and then she's holding
everything against him all the time
like the dude's like you know hey they
were gonna go to the store right
and she's like holding the credit cards
right because she
he can't have money that's how she
wanted to be you know and
she's taking forever to go they start
going she didn't even bring the credit
card
and he needed to buy something for his
car so he snapped at her they got into
an argument
and then she brings it back up again
well what you did to me
and the trust that was broken it's like
hey [ __ ] at what point are you gonna
get over this [ __ ] okay
cause if you can't get over it you ain't
ever gonna be in a good relationship
then get the [ __ ] out of it cause i'm
[ __ ] tired of that kind of [ __ ]
like what what are you talking about you
have to be able to trust a guy at a
certain point
you have to let him know he's earning it
back if not shut the [ __ ] up about it
you know it's like when somebody it's
like if you cheat on someone
and they take you back take them back
so taking them back means you're you're
gonna be able to get over it
it's not gonna happen overnight but if
you keep bringing it up at a certain
point the other person's like how many
times do i got to apologize from some
[ __ ] that i did
at what point are you gonna forgive me
not saying forget but you have to
forgive
and and so she's in the wrong in my
opinion okay and
in terms of like and this goes for all
of these people
in this show it needs to in this
situation
love is not the end all be all
okay love love like
i have a friend of mine his name's tyler
super gay you know not just regular gay
he's super gay
all right i've known him for like 10
years you know
he always making bad choices so
at a certain point he he would always
talk to me when it was too late
this the boy's using him or whatever you
know it's like
he's terrible he's on drugs or whatever
the situation was
so i told him after a while you need to
have a minimum standard
minimum standard the reason why you end
up with somebody who
ain't right for you or somebody that you
think is like
just turns out to be a bad person is
because of how you feel about yourself
it's because you don't think you deserve
better
so you look in a pool that
you think okay this is equivalent to me
or i'm better than this
have a minimum standard start to feel
good about yourself that you deserve
better even if it's minimum like i said
the next guy you
start talking to make sure they got a
job a place to stay
a car means of transportation or
they're going to school you know but
they got to have just
make that the minimum standard before
you move
forward just do that he started to see
like oh
this one came in his life oh yeah he
don't get a job
he's always asking me for money or this
one then you go let me
you start to want more for yourself
you do deserve better you do we all do
but you have to understand that you
deserve it
okay you have to feel that way about
yourself
do you deserve this because love can
happen
with anyone love is like
love is like a chemical reaction man you
know think of love as like a science
experiment
that you're pouring a bunch of things
into a beaker and you're shaking that
sucker up
and then then some of the fumes that
come off that is love
you have to decide what you put in that
beaker
before you do and that goes for the
whole 90-day fiance thing
and some of you guys that are listening
like jenny
60. should she have
went on the internet to find a guy
like you can't know enough
if you ain't in the same room with the
person you don't know who he is
where he's at but she allowed herself to
fall in love
before better circumstances were in
place
and that goes for all these people
better circumstances should have been in
place
before you decide like do you have
similar interests
you know do you do you like you know get
together see if you click
does it work you know all these kind of
things should go on before you go
you let yourself fall in love
because falling in love you can't even
control it but you can't control
who you're looking for in the love pool
this is what happens
you know this laura she's in love with
that dude allen why because
i don't know why maybe because he gave
her all this attention
they had sex maybe she's feeling like
i've been on a bunch of bad
relationships and finally someone
loves me but she don't even know what
that really feels like because she's
always in these awkward situations
you got to give yourself an opportunity
give yourself a chance to get to know
this person
even on a basic level first before you
allow yourself
to fall in love and i do mean you do
allow yourself to fall in love
because you make yourself vulnerable and
open and you
you just you just go for it for reasons
that are sometimes just superficial i
like how the person looks
you know or you only like a two or three
things about the person and you think oh
this is enough for me
and then you start spending time with
someone and it's that time that you
spend with them that you freely find out
who the [ __ ] this person really is and
that that's the point that
you're in too deep because you love them
and now the love is letting you ignore
all of these
all this behavior or how they treat you
or how it makes you feel and that's not
good enough to me
you know you and we've all done it i did
it we all we've all done it you know
we've all done it so you just have to
like you know you get to a part where
you got to be careful
like who you allow into your life and
then this internet [ __ ] is like this is
what happens
you know this is what happens just chick
tiffany
she you know she she fell in love with a
gambling addict with a criminal record
and then she you know makes her son call
him dad and then she wants to go over
there
and then [ __ ] be on the dude like a
mom
all the time making him feel like [ __ ]
and she thinks she's in the right you
ain't in the [ __ ] right
you're not in the right at a certain
point you have to let
all that [ __ ] go and build trust and a
good relationship
and then by the way by the way
got pregnant on purpose
so her decision-making she need to shut
the [ __ ] up
like like your decision-making is like
so you fall in love with a dude in south
africa they got a gambling problem let
your eight-year-old son call this dude
dad
uh he you know now he can't move over
there
you you go over there you find out the
[ __ ] place is dangerous and you
you you know the place is dangerous you
know your son don't want to be there
and you decide to get pregnant on
purpose the [ __ ] out of here
you have no business judging that dude's
decisions
none shh
shut it anyways all of us
make better choices about
the process you take to get to know
someone
at a certain point you got to be guarded
and then you open that up you open that
up
but look sometimes we let sex get in the
way we let our desires
and that those things to override
our common sense and boom you end up in
a
terrible relationship you know that's
like the guy corey he's on the [ __ ]
panel
talking about everybody else is like i
don't think you made the right choice i
wanted to
do you need to shut the [ __ ] up your
girl's over there you know
you know with the other dude and she
don't got your ring on you got enough
issues you don't need to be judging
somebody else's relationship
as i'm judging everybody's relationship
right
anyways 90 day fiance the other way
uh if it's i love hate watching it
you know i love hate watching it
another new one just came out as big
brother big brother just started again
big brother all stars
is terrible sorry i don't like it so far
but i always hate big brother
in the first few episodes but this one
was boring as hell this quarantined
version
they had this really boring game the
they weren't listening to julie
you know they just and then by the way i
don't want to see
loser ass all-stars this would be like
the nba having a tournament of like the
last
six years of teams that like here's all
this
here's all the teams that finish second
third fourth they gonna be in the
tournament
just you know to see who's the best of
those people nobody want to watch that
[ __ ]
you know like i remember why they lost i
saw all these people and i was like oh i
hate all these people i never liked any
one of these people
or it was like people from the past and
then they like it's weird how
like they're not young people anymore a
lot of them are like hi i'm 40. i got
four kids you know i used to i was on
big brother 10 years ago it's like
what so you leaving your family come do
this [ __ ] again to live in some it's
like it's a whole different mentality
and attitude that i just don't like
i don't like it yet you know but again i
love hate watching [ __ ] that i don't
like
like it almost don't even it almost
don't even make any sense why
like it's like why do you watch it you
know what i mean
all right guys got this new segment
that i'm doing right now and this um
i i wanted people to send me videos you
know
i want to i wanted people to send me
videos of
you know their questions so eventually
we're going to get to that
but this segment is real world advice
from a grown ass man
all right i'm gonna have some graphics
maybe what's the one thing you will take
away from the rest of your life from
this
pandy you know well the one thing that i
will take away from this
is that i need to
[Music]
remember that i'm not defined by
my career i'm not defined by
just being a stand-up comic or an actor
that i have to
find other things in my life that move
me that i'm passionate about
that that also can give me purpose like
hobbies like you know
or even your relationship you know it
really strengthened my relationship so
that's uh something that i got out of
that
how would you handle flaky friends who
consistently cancel plans on the last
minute
i hate this my number one is when people
are inconsiderate
i can't stand people are inconsiderate
you know so what you have to do is you
just have to
you have to make your plans and go
through with them without them
or you know you really have to redefine
like who your friends are and what they
and you have to just step up and be like
hey this is
uh this really i don't appreciate when
you don't show up on time
you say that a few times you got to let
them know like don't [ __ ] about it you
have to just really have a serious like
hey
when we make plans can you show up on
time you know because it really makes me
feel shitty when you don't
you know so you just get you got to step
up and say how you feel
you know this is one of my favorite of
these questions
this girl i'm in love with also his
friend
got a man who treats her like [ __ ] what
do i do
i mean this is what i was talking about
earlier
about feeling
that you deserve more that you deserve
better that you've
that there's just got to be a minimum
standard of how you want to be treated
now you guys out there who are in some
situation where you're like oh this is
my friend and i love her
you being a [ __ ] you gotta let your
intentions be known
you can't let this girl have her cake
and eat it too listen
she knows you got feelings for her women
know
they know but they also enjoy this
intimacy they're getting from you the
attention the
the the the comfort the the what you
provide for them emotionally as a friend
and someone who obviously cares for them
deeper than most people
who would want to lose that she getting
dick from the other guy
she getting her passions filled with
this guy that's why she
now she got the best of both worlds now
man you got to cut that off
it's not an ultimatum it's just you
taking care of yourself
you have to know your worth you have to
be like yo
i got feelings for you i don't like how
this guy treats you i know i would treat
you better
so i'm coming for it
so just let you know i want to take you
out on friday and it's going to be a
date
okay would you like to go on a date on
friday if she said well i have a
boyfriend i said hey that's not you
that's your [ __ ]
he don't treat you well you're always
telling me about it i know i could treat
you well
you know and i think that you should uh
take you should stop telling stop
talking about that dude
if if you're gonna st if if you're if
this girl you in love with
comes to you all the time like oh he
treated me shitty again don't
after after two times you go i don't
want to hear about it
you know cause that's on you now cause
how many times you gonna stay with a
dude that treats you like that
so i'm about it you want you want to be
with me
because let her know let her know and if
not
and she's like well then you go all
right well when you're ready
to be with somebody who you know cares
for you i'm gonna be here for you
and you bounce you gotta you gotta cut
back on the relationship
because all you're doing is hurting
yourself because you're sitting here
being like i because you're not treating
her better if you're
if you're letting her know you're okay
with her being with a [ __ ]
you're how are you being a friend you're
not being a friend you got to be like yo
that dude don't treat you well i don't
like it
get out of that relationship and i want
to treat you better
i will i do when you ready for that i'm
here
and you gotta like back away that's my
advice for that
did you ever struggle to leave a
relationship
yeah i think we all struggle to leave
when you want to leave a relationship
because if if you've gotten into a
relationship
you care about this person and you care
about their feelings
um and you're also you know you're
scared to hurt them or you're scared to
like
your own insecurities of being like well
can i be without this person even though
i don't like being with this person
so it becomes a struggle you know it's
hard it's hard to make that choice you
know
and by the way if it is hard maybe you
need to reevaluate do i really need to
leave this relationship or
unless you just know cause people that
just know people are like
this sucks i'm out you just leave you're
out
but leave don't cheat leave you know
but sometimes it's hard i had a breakup
even my girl and i not right now
we had a breakup in the middle it just
wasn't working out
but then i couldn't stay away from this
[ __ ]
you know we just kept you know what i
mean and then
things changed we we changed things
i changed how i talked to her she
we she did some things or so we grew
you know we saw we both saw it boom and
here we are
so if you're struggling there's a reason
why you're struggling to leave
but at the same time if there are
things that are like this is too much i
can't deal with this
then you need to face those things talk
about it and be like yo
we need to work on this and if those
things can't be fixed
then all you're doing is torturing
yourself and you got to get out
how do you get over someone you love so
often much
when you have no fam or friends near ooh
this is a good one this is like tough
quarantine stuff right here right this
is like
like how do you deal with a breakup
and you have nothing so man that's when
you have to like what i was talking
about earlier about
what defines you as a person it's not
just your career or the things that you
can't do anymore
you have to you have to keep yourself
busy you got to find purpose this is a
good time to write that script you
always wanted to write
this is a good time to start working out
you know this is a good time to start
walking every day going on runs or you
know
youtube is great for like they have
those 10 minute workouts
you can get one of those stretch band
things or do an ab workout
like build a routine of new things like
if you're sitting around
moping trying thinking about this person
then you need to start thinking about
you
focus on you maybe it's time to do that
spring cleaning
maybe it's time to read that book you've
always wanted to read maybe it's time to
take up a new hobby you know there's a
lot of things you could do
but you know you can't be defined by
just that relationship
and you have to know find out about
yourself
like who are you now what are your
interests what have you not been doing
because you were in that relationship
that you always wanted to do
or were you folk you know what i mean
like i remember a breakup i had i
realized i was focusing all my life
on making sure she was okay and then i
wasn't doing [ __ ] for myself
you know and that's around the time i
started
when after that breakup it was around
the time i started doing comedy i was
like because
i hadn't been doing it and i should have
been but anyways so that's what i'm
saying
so look at yourself and be like what can
i do to really improve my life right now
and distract yourself keep busy you know
that's all you can really do but uh good
luck you know
here's one i like is having the same
humor in a relationship
important um i don't know to me
no you know i sometimes it's like i'm a
comic
so i know my girl don't always like my
humor she comes to the shows and she's
like i didn't get that joke i didn't
like that i don't understand why people
are laughing it doesn't bother me
you know because she when she's my
audience i know how to make her laugh
we have a great time we laugh all the
time because
our collective humor in a relationship
is different from
you know my humor there's a little bit
of it they cross
mingle you know you know they you know
they cross pollinate sometimes but
i don't think it's important that you
guys both have this the same sense of
humor
but i do think it's important that like
you know like the type of humor
it can't be like such a disparity you
know if you like always like dark
jokes and it makes the other person
really uncomfortable like uh why did you
think that was funny
you know then you might have a problem
there but i don't think you have to have
the same humor
but you have to you know you have to
understand each other's humor i think
that's important
how can i start my journey to a
healthier lifestyle how did you start
well the pandemic pandemic made me start
because i was eating less
not going out to restaurants having that
you know just delicious
buttery big portions of food all the
time
had to start cooking for myself started
having oatmeal in the morning
i started taking supplements and
vitamins that were good for me because i
went and got a blood test and so i saw i
was like vitamin d deficient
i found out like oh cholesterol was
going to start being a problem so
then i saw i started doing preventative
preventative techniques which is
important
you need to find out where you are on
your health like where is your health
like where do you stand
you know a lot of times we just don't
know we need to go find out and then you
just make the choice to improve those
things
you have to want to improve your life
when you want to improve your life
and then you start taking steps to
improve your life but only takes one
step
it's just one thing you have to do if
it's get up and walk for 10 minutes
every day
that's the first step if it's like okay
well in the morning i'm not going to
have like a savory breakfast i'm just
gonna have oatmeal
maybe a half a bagel like you know you
just make these choices you know
and then you just you know it's really
simple you just eat less
eat less add vegetables but you don't
have to like
go on some like strict ass diet no no
just eat less of what you're already
eating
you you realize oh man i don't need to
eat this full portion of this like
i started to do that when you go to
steakhouse you go maybe i don't need the
steak potatoes and this and all that
maybe i just need like the steak which i
love
and some broccoli you know you just make
these little little adjustments
turn into turn into like big life
changes
so that's what i suggest good luck
hooked up a few times with a good friend
whose actions are like dating yet
insists we
are friends well i mean
haven't we all been there not everybody
can handle
[ __ ] buddy situations you just can't
you know but it's amazing how much more
honest
you are in that situation if you think
about it
because a lot of times you're saying to
yourself
i really like having sex with this
person but
i know i can't be in a relationship with
this person but i love the sex
so you've decided to keep that distance
like that we've all had
situations like that you know but what
you've allowed yourself to do
is you start to have feelings like you
know you
it's hard to like be that intimate with
someone and especially depending on
how you particularly deal with sex
some people like having a like a mental
emotional physical con
like that kind of connection and that's
what makes it better it's not just
the physical act i think most of us are
like that right i don't know you tell me
think about it for yourself right now as
you listen to me talk about this
how do you enjoy sex what's the best sex
you've ever had
sometimes it is it because of that
connection or was it because of the
circumstances you know you was like
it was like wrong and it was like ooh
you know this person's not right for you
and so it made you
you know you have to think about how sex
affects you emotionally
it has an effect on you know and then
you you sometimes
translate that into like oh well i have
feelings
i have feelings because this was so
powerful this sexual attraction and what
we went through
was so good that it made me i know i
this is the love of my life now
it doesn't always mean that you know
it's just it's triggered in different
ways you know you talk about you got
you know pheromones and there's chemical
reactions that you're
that we're having that are different
with each person each connection you
know
it's just different so in this situation
the dude probably acting like that
because
that's what that makes for good sex for
him
you know but it's but that doesn't mean
that he necessarily has those feelings
real feelings for you so you have to ask
yourself why are you doing this
again you have to want better for
yourself you know if you really
want to be with that person then you got
to be like now you can't
you can't have them your cake and eat it
too like what's going on with us
and you have to just know that you can
move on and there'll be other guys who
are going to love having sex with you
also
they're going to be other guys that
you're going to have a connection with
that's going to be bigger and better so
that's he's not the only guy in the
whole wide world that's not the end just
because you feel that feeling
it don't mean like that's the only time
you're ever going to feel that feeling
i'm telling you you can connect with
anyone if you allow yourself
so get out of that [ __ ] what are some
tips for living on your own
i'm 20 and new to this whole adult thing
well first of all i want to say
good for you if you 20 and you're
already out living on your own
you already doing good all right
just be responsible use some common
sense
make sure you can pay your bills save
money i'm not you don't have to save all
your money but you got to put some money
aside for things
because [ __ ] happens and you know figure
out how you want to live are you
you know be clean take care of yourself
look you know take care of your
environment
just you know you're doing good if
you're out there living on your own
you're already taking a great step that
a lot of people can't take
so just work on
being responsible for yourself because
now there's nobody you could turn to and
be like
and your parents are probably still
helpful they're probably you probably
like you have a monthly like oh i can't
pay this and your parents will probably
be like all right here we'll help you
but don't rely on that but start relying
on yourself and know that the buck stops
with you
good luck this one's tough um
advice for teachers
we are struggling right now man
i think teachers were probably
struggling even before this
but the thing that gave you joy and
purpose was
knowing that you were molding young
minds
so you were living your fantasy you were
living your dream of like i always
wanted to be a teacher or you've
accepted like oh i'm a great teacher and
i love this so that purpose has been
taken away
and once that purpose has been taken
away now you're sitting here going
damn i can't pay my bills and then you
go oh man
this is the amount of money i was making
then you start to go damn i wasn't even
being appreciated enough as it is
and you've lost that thing that kept you
going in there
i don't know i really i wish i had an
answer for this one
you know it's like we all have to try to
find a way to
pivot you know
as a teacher you have a lot of skills
and a lot of knowledge
it might be time to like refocus on to
something else
try to see if you could maybe continue
going to school
yourself or you know probably got a few
more credits to get a different degree
uh find other interests
i mean i wish i wish i had an answer and
i feel for all these people
i feel for all the people that are
struggling especially with jobs like
that
service jobs and you know jobs that you
know
that were important to society
that we don't appreciate enough you know
it sucks and and i really
wish i had something better to say about
it but all i can really say is just hang
in there
and try to find purpose in other areas
of your life
so you're not depressed about the
situation that's going on and then
hopefully we will eventually get back to
normal
we just have to pray for the doctors and
scientists that they get this [ __ ] right
but my heart goes out to you and
again i hope that things get better for
all of us
how do i make friends in a new city i've
been here for five months and know
zero people well i mean you gotta get
out man what are your hobbies and
interests
i would start at work you know you
obviously have interest you have
same interests as people at work so i
think some people at work you got to be
like
hey tom you want to go to lunch or you
know just start finding people there
and then if not what are your interests
in hobbies you know
you got to get out and start doing
things you know i think i think online
is good for that too i mean i know
right now it's tough but you know there
are communities out there you know there
are
chat rooms and you know there's like
forums and groups you know you start
talking to someone but
believe me get off that [ __ ] right away
though you know you meet somebody you
had the same interest with you got to be
like hey let's talk
you know get on dating apps and just
start talking to people
i mean it's difficult right now because
of the world we're living in but hey you
gotta you gotta
if you have zero friends i mean that's
partly you do you even want
friends i mean are are you too shy like
you have to like look at yourself and be
like what am i doing that i'm not
getting out and meeting people what
about your neighbors what about like
there's
people all around you all the time that
you have common interest with
i just think you should open yourself up
start saying hello to people that work
more start being like hey how you doing
hey what's going on you know
start learning a little bit about people
you know how was your weekend and
somebody says oh well my daughter blah
blah blah
next time you see them you're like hey
how's your daughter uh
such and such you know and then you just
that you know that's how you build
connections is you just have to listen
you know you have to you have to give
people
what you're trying to get back from
people first that's
a great way you leave we read about this
in these communication books you know
when you want something first you got to
find out what the other person wants
and see if you can achieve that because
then
you'll be able to focus on you you know
you'll eventually get what you want in
that process
so i just say open yourself up be a
little bit more vulnerable
and see if people can
people connect with you how does a grown
ass man balance
warzone and a needy ass girlfriend
this is basically just like how do you
have your own personal
hobby or something that you really enjoy
doing
without making your girlfriend feel like
this is more important than her
it's a difficult balance i gotta tell
you for me it's worked out because
i make money so it's turned into a job
for me like i would
like going online and playing video
games in front of the people that watch
me i have subscribers
you know it's made opportunities for me
i'm working now
it's work so lucky me right but still at
the same time
you don't want to be somebody that's
always working all the time so i think
you have to
you have to give your girl a date night
date day you have to give her a day
like where like something concrete not
to say that you don't do anything on the
other days i'm saying
you have to have something like this is
your day this is your day
we're gonna do this with you that's what
we're gonna do
me and you baby we're gonna do this and
you have that day
you have a date night you have to you
have to carve out time for her because
she's important to you that's why you're
asking this question
if your girl is important to you then
make time for her
there's time for everything you can play
warzone all day and still give her a lot
of time and attention so
you have to learn how to do that you
know re
remember why you're with why you are
with her
and give her the attention that she
deserves and need
all right everybody uh that's uh it for
grown
real world advice from a grown ass man
if you would like to send a question
you know each week i'll put put up my
instagram post but i would love for
people to send me
a video of the question you might have
and be like hey
i'm having this issue what do you think
listen i'm no doctor i'm just giving you
my thoughts
and perspectives if you appreciate my
thoughts and perspectives i'll be glad
to answer your questions
and if you also have some things you
want me to talk about if there's some
topics you know is there a show you want
me to review
or anything like that please send me an
email at eric ericgriffin.com
or i see also see my instagram dms you
can send them there too
well that's it for uh riffing with
griffin this week
again i got uh big episodes coming up
but these are big episodes now this is
how i'm gonna do it i love doing solo
episodes i don't know why i wasn't doing
this from the
i was doing it in the very beginning and
i remember how much i loved it but
it just became about oh you got to get
views and all these people got to watch
and then it's like then
i messed myself up because so many
people started watching
and they only watch because they're a
fan of the person that i had on
and i want you to be a fan of me so if
you're a person that you only want to
see
other people just unsubscribe you know
what i mean you don't need these
notifications
getting in your way just like i i just
want
the people who are fans of me you want
to see me
talk talk [ __ ] talk about movies talk
about shows talk about what's going on
in life
i'm here for you and this is what this
podcast is going to be about it's
riffing with griffin
and so instead of always riffing with
other people the guests
i'm riffing with you guys now you know
so let's rip off your topics and
discussions
and eventually i might even have a
call-in section where
you know you call in on skype and we'll
talk
i'll get you you know and then like that
too so we'll see how it's going
but anyways i really appreciate you
watching it and as always you know
please subscribe and share if you're if
you so inclined and if you want to see
me game every day
if you're into gaming videos you want to
watch like watching people play video
games
i'm on i'm on every day on twitch that's
eric griffin gaming
so yeah here it is
thank you for watching another episode
of riffing with griffin
and i will see you next week
you